> ORNING WE'VE SEEN WHATE FOR TN
DING MOTHER OF THREE  ATARE .E
UNKERED DOWN WH
HER  IN HEOTHER'S
HOANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOININ, E.
U  CLD
>>.N THIENU LLS WHAT I FORL DAYS
A NMA
Y AND I THIN
ITIKTEPPNO
IT OUR REA N WE'REUST  TRYING
T ALEXAND, PRAYINTE
ED YOU?OW WHA
ENDU M CHI I
DSG.E'S LIOW, WORR
ALL THE TIME
S UPT NIGHT.
OSTAYED AT MY HOUSE,
WE HEARDWALATILEUAERE.ER
BUDL 4
YEARS OLD.
E DON'UNDERSTANDINA MEE SHE
TH
AROUND AND IT'AYNT HERRE
HE'SEPIGHTHE DNG
I THS
E EP
HOPING.'RE THERE WITH A 'M
7-YEAR-OLD, A
1-YEAR-OLD.
CAN YOLL WHAT  ISUPPLIES LIKE O
ATM THE E
SO THET N PEO OU
CITYFT IN THE ORNA -HITED, I'M S
DSCANS,
LEL SUPPLI FOR A WEEK OR SO.ERAO
PE DE MECIG IS , HAVE Y
WITHSIAN
AREA YS WITH
THANVE THEY BEN'
FROM T DT.E NOALR,HETOREMY BEST
G  RIGHT. PPL
HE IF
IT CYING TO
OVER TIME  C THETHE GE.
JUST  SEE WHERSON WTAD
AMAEAY U N   IIVING T  US THIS
>>>>O G.
TSE
THIS RUSSIAN SI.NF
HUMANITARIANFFORTS,